for a multimedia performance group and
we're from Austin Texas and our
specialty just happens to be playing
music through a big audio modulated
Tesla coils we also have a robot drummer
and we play instruments and stuff with
play guitars and bass guitars and
keyboards and things like that
so basically our Tesla coils are a
little different than traditional Tesla
coils in a matter that they are solid
state that means that they use
transistors and so basically what ends
up happening is we have a computer that
we have built and we have programmed to
interpret MIDI data and we take that
information and we turn it into
fiber-optic light pulse with a
microcontroller which goes into a
digital logic circuit board inside our
Tesla coils which controls the pulse
rate modulation which allows us to
change the pitch of the spark that we're
producing from the Tesla coil each one
draws 220 volts from the wall and they
can draw up to 50 amps but depending on
the note that we're playing out of it
varies it can be anywhere from 5 to 50
amps and on the output each one of the
testicles can produce up to a half
million volts and maybe up to an amp of
peak RMS current
when you're electrocuted it's because
your body is passing a current right so
if your head is at half a million volts
and your feet is at zero volts then
you're going to be passing current right
and so what the what the Faraday cage
does is it encapsulate your whole body
right so the voltage potential of your
head and your feet are the same so if
your head is at a million volts and your
feet is that a million volts that means
that the zero volts across your body and
so you're passing no amps and that's
that's basically why it works the way it
goes